[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I want
to start out first
by just giving a little
explanation or back
story about why we're here.
I have what you would
call a pretty complicated
orthopedic history.
I don't want to go
into all the detail.
But I've had 17
surgeries on my joints.
Really long story.
There's a lot of causes.
There's genetics.
There's my personality.
I'm stubborn.
I come from a small town, didn't
have a lot of information,
and things like that.
But as you can imagine, I've
done and seen a lot of things.
I've had surgeries a lot of you
probably have never heard of,
and I hope you never hear of.
Tried procedures, modalities.
I've had stem cell injections.
I've had all kinds of things.
And when I look back
on it, I learned a lot.
And at the end of it
all, I said to myself,
I wish everyone else knew this.
Or I wish I knew that then.
And so I wanted to pick
some people in my past
that if I had known them when
I was 16, before this all
happened, what would have
changed because I don't want
anyone else-- I'm
not saying any of you
are going to have-- this
won't happen to everyone.
I'm like a 0.001% kind of case.
But there's a lot of things
that could be prevented.
So I actually ran into
Gray's work actually
after the 17 surgeries.
I had all this surgery.
And my body was not moving well.
I had all this cartilage
put back in my body.
But still in pain.
And hearing about
his work and how
he explains movement, all
these things, one thing
I want to share with you is
this is stuff that all of us
should know in high
school, grade school.
This should be our health class.
These are things we should know
to make decisions, health care
decisions.
There's no reason why you
only a physical therapist
or an elite trainer should
know some of the stuff
that Gray's going
to talk about today.
So that's why invited Gray here.
And I've seen Gray talk
to fitness professionals,
medical professionals,
those people.
But there's no reason why he
can't talk to the rest of us.
This is all stuff we should
know to help us make decisions.
So I don't want to steal
any more of Gray's time.
He's a physical
therapist, strength coach,
works with elite athletes,
works with the military.
There's a ton of
things I can say.
He's written two books.
"Movement," I recommend
everyone really read that one.
That's my favorite of the two.
They're both great though.
But without further
ado, Gray Cook.
GRAY COOK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm excited to do this because
it's really easy to lecture
to a group of your peers
because you can drop terms
and terminology and systems that
everybody is supposed to know.
But when I got invited
to do this, and some
of the conversations I had
with Steve preparing for it,
he alluded to the fact that when
he looked at our systematic way
we look at human
movement, it just
looks like a good
engineering approach.
And that's probably because
he's heard me make analogies
like the human movement,
information system,
and other information processing
have many common problems.
One of the first ways I
talk to patients or athletes
is, is this a hardware
or software problem.
Sometimes, your structure,
the structure of your body,
is the reason you can't get
that next thing out of movement.
And sometimes,
it's the function.
It's the processing.
It's real easy in
health care for us
to just look at you
as a bag of parts.
Your name isn't x.
It's knee.
You're the knee in room three.
Right?
And as long as we do what
we gotta do for the knee,
then yeah, you're taking
some anti-inflammatories,
but we upset your stomach.
Oh, now, you're a GI problem.
Oh, we're going to get
you over somewhere else.
And many of the things we
do, I'll be honest with you,
are to cover up your symptoms
so you'll leave us alone,
not to make you more
independent and make
that independence sustainable.
You graduate from high school.
You can read and write
letters enough to get
through the rest of your
life or go to college
or do something else.
And you can do the same thing
with numbers, just enough,
hopefully, to stay
out of debt, if you
know how to work the numbers.
But most of us
graduate high school
not knowing how to
read, write, or correct
faulty movement patterns.
I would suggest that many of
you can correct your movement
patterns just by
changing your lifestyle,
not by adopting new
exercise practices.
Your lifestyle could
be compounding that.
But unless we have
systems and filters that
point us right to
where the problem is,
you're just going to meet a
bunch of people with a hammer.
And guess what happens
when you've got a hammer?
Everything looks like a nail.
So you just look
like a nail to them.
OK?
If they have a
screwdriver, and so on.
OK?
So there's many, many things
that I can talk about about
the way the human brain
operates this sensory apparatus
because most people look at
the body as muscles and joints
to move us from place to place.
There's only two things we
do with our body-- locomotion
and manipulation.
We tweedle with stuff and
interact with our environment,
or we move from space to space.
Everything in your
brain is set up, almost,
to do that because unless you
can engage your environment,
whether that environment
is very social with a lot
of other people, or it's
absolutely natural with rocks
and sticks and avalanches
and snakes and stuff
like that, either
way, you've got
to pick up that information.
How do you pick up
that information?
Data points or patterns?
Because the human
movement learning system
does some things that we still
can't do with software yet.
OK?
We've got computers that
got pretty good at chess.
They still can't
throw a curve ball.
We don't know the
algorithms to do that.
And the minute it knows
how to throw a curve ball,
it can't switch up and
throw something else.
It becomes a highly specialized
robot throwing curveballs.
All right?
So what we do on the front
end of movement is perception.
And when we teach
you an exercise
or teach you how
to be an athlete
or teach you how to do your
next new sport you just
watched on YouTube, we
focus on the behavior.
What's the best way
to change behavior?
Change perception.
If I change your perception
of something that's going on,
the natural driving force,
the same driving force that
makes every kid learn
to walk on their own--
we don't use personal trainers
or physical therapists
for that.
Kids learn to walk on their own.
And when you think about
going from a blob--
they can't even roll over--
to running in two years,
going from where you are now to
an Olympic gold medal does not
have as much processing in
your brain as that does,
going from the blob to the
running thing, no help at all.
I need you to be thinking
of that because there
is a distinct difference
in what we would do, say,
with code or software and the
way we've got to program this.
And I hope I can tell you
the story of how that works.
And at the end,
if I stay on time,
I'd like to show you a real
time example of what that means.
We don't write movement code.
So thinking that
we can change it
is not really honoring the code.
We're just hacking in.
Oh, I can get your core to fire.
I can get your ankle to move.
Oh, I can get your cardio up.
All we're doing
is hacking a code
that maybe we don't
particularly appreciate
because almost every time
we do something in fitness
to make you better, damn if
we don't make three mistakes.
If we go back 50
years in our history,
the people that used to exercise
in this country on a regular
basis seemed healthier and more
fit than the people who didn't.
That's not the same anymore.
The people who exercise
regularly right now
in our culture are more fit than
people that don't, but they're
not more healthy.
They actually have more
musculoskeletal issues
than people who
choose not to express
their self physically
three times a week
in a package of exercise.
Exercise is a friggin'
risk factor now for health,
not fitness.
Exercise will allow you to do
more of what you want to do.
Just keep doing more of it
and you'll do more of it
until you blow up.
But is it really
making you healthier
when 80% of the
runners in a given year
will not be able to run.
And they want to
run, but they can't.
They created a health
issue trying to be fit.
Don't put your fitness on
a movement dysfunction,
and you won't have to see that.
I think we need to learn to
read movement code better first.
And if we can read
that code better,
I think there are a lot of
brains in the world that just
have a slight paradigm shift.
Don't look at me
as a bag of parts.
Don't tell me that structure
always governs function,
because it doesn't.
Structure has a big
influence on function.
But let me ask you a question.
Does a right-handed
tennis player
have twice the bone
density in this forearm
because they were
born that way and it's
a good thing they played
tennis on this side?
Or did the act of squeezing the
crap out of that tennis racket
at impact create more
compressive forces
on the bone, which put in action
a thing called Wolff's law
that adds greater bone
density any time we're
going to need greater stress.
You don't just get bigger
muscles when you work out.
Your bone density goes up.
So a lot of times,
function governs structure.
When kids start throwing
really early in their life,
overhand, they remodel their
entire shoulder mechanics.
And I can see, when
you're 35 years old
and haven't picked up
a baseball in 20 years,
that you through a
lot when you were
a kid just by the signature
that it left on you.
We have a little saying in the
clinic when an athlete comes
through and they've run their
self right into the ground.
Running has left a
bigger mark on you
than you left on running.
You embarked on this journey
to leave a mark on running.
And it left a mark on
you that's probably going
to be here for a few months.
Let's see if we can go back
and resume the activity
with integrity so you
can achieve independence
and you can sustain that
as long as possible.
All right, I'm not an engineer.
And I'm a redneck with dyslexia.
So I was challenged in every
academic endeavor I ever
approached because I
couldn't memorize things
that I couldn't put in a pattern
or a sequence that made sense
to me.
But once I could, I didn't
have to remember it.
Now, I also happen to
be pretty good in art.
A lot of people thought
I took art all the way
through high school
to keep my GPA up
just enough to play football.
And that also was true.
But when I got to
University of Miami,
I realized that most
of my peers were
taking volumes and
volumes of notes
in anatomy, gross anatomy.
We spent our whole
summer on gross anatomy
because to be a
physical therapist,
you've got to be able to
really interact and almost name
every muscle in the body.
The MD's looked at
muscles in groups.
We looked at the
organs in groups.
But we looked at the
muscles individually.
I drew pictures.
And it helped me because
I could close my eyes
and then rotate that
picture in my head.
And it helped me
start to develop
an appreciation for movement.
I didn't really fit
the academic model.
But it really helped
me having, I guess,
the dyslexia, but also
maybe a little bit
of photographic
memory because as soon
as I could see a pattern, I
could see when it would deviate
from the norm enough where it
would actually change itself.
So that's what got me here.
And if I can find a pattern,
I think I can interact,
I think I can see some things.
And if I can't find a
pattern, a lot of times
I won't comment on it.
It gave me an advantage
against some of my obstacles.
And I never forgot
some of the things
I learned in physical
therapy school
because over here,
we're learning
about the neurological system.
And I tell you what.
If a family member
in your lifetime
has a stroke, a CVA,
cerebral vascular accident,
we don't put them
on weight machines,
and we don't put
them on a treadmill.
If they lose their ability to
walk with nice, fluid stride,
that recognizable stride that's
been part of their movement
signature all their life,
and all of a sudden you
see your mom or dad
dragging a foot,
it's going to hit
you pretty hard.
They come to our clinic.
They don't walk
in parallel bars.
They don't walk on a treadmill.
They got to get
down on the ground
and go through
Operating System 101.
Why?
Because the first time
they learned to walk,
they had to crawl first.
It is not me trying to make
them humble or humiliate them.
If they fall in Walmart, they're
going to have a lot worse time.
I'm going to confront every
fear you've got right here.
And we're going to engage
that natural operating
system because the part of a
stroke that most people don't
realize is part of
your brain died.
But another part of your
brain, within a window,
is willing to take
that information
and actually remodel
your walking platform.
But if we focus too much on
your walking and not enough
on what got you there,
we'll never get there.
If we make your walking about
just strengthening that toe
so you don't drag it,
we are dishonoring
the operating system that
made you walk the first time.
And that's the big
problem we got.
So I've been a
physical therapist.
I was a strength coach.
I was very, very much
into orthopedics.
And I was trying to get my
board certification specialize
and change the world
my own little way.
And then I was
brought to my knees,
humbly, by that first little
girl right there, Jessica.
One reason is she had colic.
Therefore, by default,
I got insomnia.
Right?
So we spent a lot
of time about 3:00
in the morning just looking
at each other saying, what
am I going to do with you.
And she's like,
well, I don't know.
What am I going to do with you?
And I watched her
teach herself how
to walk the very first time.
And I offered nothing
but a safe environment.
Right?
Get your scissors off the floor.
Get the sharp
corners out of there.
And she did it.
She pulled it off.
And the funny thing is, when we
watch, as physical therapists,
the child go from barely
crawling and rolling
to running, as long
as a child meets
their developmental
milestones, meaning
they hit crawling by here.
There's a window.
As long as they
make that window,
we don't measure how
much their ankles move
or how strong their biceps are.
Make your window.
When they don't make the
window, that's when we go in
and look and see what can we do
to add that more sensory input.
Well, we've got
children all the time
that skip that crawling phase.
Well, how do you
make a child crawl?
Favorite toy goes in a tube.
They'll figure it out.
Right?
You can't walk in that tube.
You can't roll in that tube.
You've got to
crawl in that tube.
And so that's the way we do it.
Perception drives behavior.
And most of us try to
change our movement behavior
without changing the
way our body perceives
the environments
and the obstacles
that we call exercise,
play, recreation, work.
So second sister comes
along, completely
different set of
movement skills.
But they both make walking
right at the same time.
One crawled forever.
One rolled, crawled
for about five minutes,
got through the stage, but
did it enough to do it good
and moved on.
Then a few years back, I don't
know if you guys remember,
but the NFL was locked out.
I do a lot of work with
the NFL in the spring.
You leave a redneck
at home in the spring,
you get another kid.
So I think 21, 18, four.
Stuff happens.
OK.
We'll move on from that.
That helped me really
look at the top
notch physical therapists
and strength coaches
and chiropractors.
I mean, we work
with all disciplines
because as far as
I'm concerned, I
was in a tribe called physical
therapy, but I left that tribe.
I'm in a tribe
called movement now.
And if you're doing the movement
stuff, you're in the truck.
Greg Rose, the co-director
of the Titleist Performance
Institute is a chiropractor.
We're best buddies.
He lectures with us.
We lecture with him.
And he makes a
statement all the time.
If you're getting
treated right now
and you can tell the difference
between a chiropractor
and a physical therapist,
they're not as good
as they could be because we're
merging the best of everything
that makes you move and
trying to protect ourself
from our own BS.
And one of the best ways we
can do that is first move
well, then move often.
What is well?
That's where I started my work.
If I can define
"well," then that
works because all this
is is natural selection.
Environments like
organisms that are
willing to adapt and respond.
If you specialize too much,
stuff is going to change,
and you're going
to get left behind.
If you don't specialize
enough to survive
the immediate
things here, you're
going to get left behind too.
So there's an interplay,
a relationship
between every organism
in every environment.
You've got to perceive and
receive the information.
You've got to respond to it.
If you deplete your energy
resources in one direction,
you're not going to
be left in the other.
So I'm going to
take this around.
But I've got to start
philosophical first.
About 1980, we didn't do well.
Exercise was, how
much can you do?
How often are you exercising?
And when I was getting
my undergrad degree
in exercise science,
we looked at exercise
three different ways--
frequency, intensity,
and duration.
Right?
How often are you doing it?
How intense are you doing it?
And when you do it,
how long can you do it?
And that's all we cared about.
So most runners are so busy
focusing on their "quantified"
life-- their Fitbit, their
heart rate, their VO2,
their body comp, but you can
hear them running 50 yards
away.
Can you hear an Indian
running 50 yards away?
Can you hear an
aboriginal hunter-gatherer
running 50 yards away?
No, because they wouldn't be
hunting if you could hear them.
And if you work with
some martial artists
and see how they
can go from a stance
to a sprint barely making
any noise, that's integrity.
That's respecting
the environment.
Right?
But if you're so
tuned in to your iPod
that you can't hear
the boom, boom, boom--
how many people in here have
noise-canceling earbuds?
I fly a lot so I got some.
Put them in.
Don't plug it into anything.
Hit the noise canceling.
And go for a walk or a run.
And it'll sound like somebody
is dropping a jackhammer.
And that's you
dropping a jackhammer
because the lack of integrity
that you hit the ground with.
So that beats up your fascial
system, your muscular system,
your tendons, and your joints.
So I think there should
be a minimum quality
because you could
take move out of this
and it would almost
work in any profession
for a skill set you're
trying to develop.
Hit a minimum
level of competency
before you start asking
me about quantities,
or what's your minimum
level of quality.
I had a lot of fitness
professionals this summer.
A lot of people are still trying
to get their head around that.
I'm like, let me
make a different.
How many single people
I got in the audience?
There we go.
I can have every one of
you a date in five minutes
as long as standards
don't matter.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
You just assumed I
was going to match you
with Mr. Or Mrs. Right.
No, I'm not.
I'm just going to put you with
somebody because we didn't talk
about the minimum standards that
are making this being single
so difficult right now.
But that's the whole point.
When anybody asks a
question about exercise,
the subject of the sentence
is not the exercise,
it's who is receiving it.
That's the subject
of the sentence.
And yet, we will have
a long blogs about,
should I front
squat or back squat.
Should I cycle if I have
knee problems or just swim?
What should I do?
We don't know who you are.
You're asking a random question
for a specific problem.
Guess what kind of answer
you're going to get.
Unbelievably random and
probably not too applicable.
You've got to move
well enough to respond.
Your response is based on that
perception and that behavior.
Act on feedback loops,
minimizing failure.
Almost every reason we're doing
our kids a disservice right
now in athletics is because
Mom and Dad and many coaches
are operating on a
success strategy.
How do I mold this kid
into the next blank?
Wrong.
It's not the way you do it.
At every level of
movement, at every level
of physical development,
at every level
of social development, at every
level of teamwork or whatever,
just don't fail.
And if you don't
fail long enough,
you will be in position to
make the moves up when you can.
But I need your movement
health at a non-failure.
Then I need your movement
literacy, your ability
to read and write
movement patterns.
I'm not asking how
fit you are yet.
I'm saying, can you go all
the way down on this knee
and come up?
That's called a lunge.
Can you do it on this knee?
Can you go all the way down
and come all the way up
on both feet?
That's called a squat.
Can you cover the
developmental movement patterns
that got you here?
And if you can't,
don't you think
that's the starting point?
Or do you think
your training heart
rate's the starting point?
Move often enough to adapt.
Here's the thing that
blows a lot of people away.
If I introduce you to a
completely new activity,
in the first three to
four-- some people will
say five or six-- weeks
of that new activity,
your strength graph
looks like that.
And then it looks like that.
It sort of tapers off.
Your greatest gains
are always going
to be in the introduction
of a new movement pattern.
And yet, in that three to four
weeks, your body changes not.
Your bone density
hasn't changed yet.
Your fascia hasn't had
a chance to remodel.
Your muscles aren't
doing anything different,
and they're no bigger.
And you probably haven't
even lost that much fat.
What happened?
Your timing, your
coordination, your processing,
your perception, and your
behaviors got better.
And just in that
amount of time, you
have refined your software
because your body is not
going to allocate precious
resources-- calories, right?
I'm going to hold on to that
Guinness as long as I can.
I'm not going to--
your body's not
going to allocate its precious
resources to making new tissue
or developing your legs
and removing tissue
from your upper body
because now you're a runner.
It's not going to move.
It's not going to reorganize
anything architecturally
until it maximizes
software first.
Isn't that when you should
probably upgrade a device?
When the software hits
the limits of the hardware
can hold?
And that's when the
body gets a ping.
And your bones get
a little denser.
And your arches get
a little higher.
And your core gets
a little tighter.
And your shoulders go back.
And your lung
volume goes up, not
because your lungs got bigger.
That's not good lung volume.
That's really good lung volume.
It's not hard to see.
But your body won't start
morphing and changing
and adapting until your
software is optimized.
But what if you learned
how to rock climb or cycle
or paddle a canoe or do some
mixed martial arts or just
do spin class with a really
bad movement pattern?
You're four rows back.
The spin teacher can't see
your knee caved in like that.
You're not doing it well.
But you're doing it often.
You just hit Save on a
pretty shitty document.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
Because when we impose
stress and load and variety
and complexity on a movement
pattern, your body assumes,
oh, we've done all we
can do at software.
Let's start morphing hardware.
Is a bone spur the
result of that maybe?
How about a stress fracture?
There's only three things
walking around this planet that
get stress fractures--
human beings,
race horses, and
greyhounds, or racing dogs.
And if we would leave
the horses alone and let
the dogs do what they want, they
wouldn't get stress fractures.
But we push them into places
they wouldn't otherwise
go in nature.
And we do the same
thing to ourself.
And so we don't recognize
stress fractures in nature
except in people who like
quantities more than qualities.
Nothing in nature breaks
that rule, not one.
And we've lost our standard
of authentic human movement.
Where do we find it again?
Well, we've got a
lot of people trying
to eat like we ate 10,000 years
ago, called the paleo diet.
If you're not going
to move like they did,
don't worry about
eating like they did.
Principle 2-- now, you
go into health care,
the Hippocratic
Oath says do no harm
because in your enthusiasm
to help somebody
through this challenging
episode in their life,
you can often remove one
problem and create two.
If we are going to interact
with your movement life,
if I'm going to see you,
my first order of business
is to protect you from
things that could make you
worse in your immediate future.
And if that means
you're a runner,
and I got to pull
you off running,
I am not saying you don't run
for the rest of your life.
I want you back.
That's where your flow state is.
That's keeping
you off of Prozac.
Right?
I'm all for that.
But not today.
You take your BMW to the shop.
The mechanic's not going to run
along beside you in a school
zone while you're
running your errands
and diagnose your car's problem.
They're going to be
like, leave it here.
You go over there.
I almost got to do
that with your body.
So sometimes, we've got
to stop a bad behavior
or break a bad pattern before
I can re-install a new one.
Otherwise, guess
which one you're
going to run more frequently?
The one that's most accessible.
So your bad running
stride, you need
to forget that while I'm
opening up your hip mobility
and showing you a different
way to train your core.
And believe it or not, I'm
going to have you doing cardio
the whole time.
But it's going to look a
lot more like a VersaClimber
or a jump rope until
you learn to hit
the ground with integrity and
store the energy like you're
supposed to.
OK?
A lot of people don't
like to hear that.
They'd just rather put
a strap on this knee,
use Ibuprofen as
a breakfast food,
don't let me interfere
with your run.
All right?
And as Mark Twain said, denial
ain't just a river in Egypt.
To be clear, I got to protect
you before I correct you.
Now, when I'm doing
corrective exercise,
that's different because
I magnify your mistakes.
I put you in a situation
where it's absolutely obvious
that your mistake is magnified.
I did this a long time
ago with people who
would get in the squat rack.
And they would shift
all the way over here.
And you try to, hey, get
back up in the middle.
The language of movement is not
written in words and pictures.
So trying to coach somebody
with visual pictures and words
has to go through three filters
of their own personality
before it gets to
where it needs to be.
If I know somebody is
squatting off line,
I get one of those slick
little slide boards
and put the little parachute
booties on both feet
and say, squat down.
And this foot just spins out.
And I'm like, squat
without that spinning out.
That's really hard.
I got to concentrate.
Good.
Next week you won't have to.
But right now, squat right there
without your foot spinning out.
You don't have the slide board?
Put on your slickest socks.
Go find a hardwood floor.
Try to squat down with
your feet pointing forward.
Whichever one's
spinning out is the one
you're pushing off
of in the squat rack.
We could easily fix that.
But I'm not going
to fix it while you
got 300 pounds on your back.
OK?
And we don't tune your car
when it's running wide open.
Cut my hands off.
So we don't need to.
By the way, of
the three things I
said-- protect,
correct, or develop--
which is training wheels?
Do training rules make
you a better cyclist?
No, or they'd be using
them in the Tour de France.
One guy just passes you on
the mountain with the training
wheels.
I gotta get me some of those.
[LAUGHTER]
The training wheels actually
don't correct or develop you.
They simply protect your
child from allowing a mistake
to become an accident.
That's it.
And there's two ways to
get a kid riding a bike.
One is let him worry about
propulsion without balance.
The other is get them
one of those bicycles you
see it REI now that
have no pedals on them
and let them get
their balance first.
There's no right way.
And if you have a wrench,
you can take the pedals off
of any bike and put it
back on when you want to.
The point being, all
those training wheels do
is let your child develop
confidence and interact
in an activity so they
will have the drive
to deal with the few falls
that are going to happen.
Every kid is going to
fall with that bike.
And that's my job.
OK?
I'm out there with the first
aid kit, first time riding.
All right, they're
going to go down.
We've got to get over that.
But I think you all understand
that those training wheels
don't make better bikers.
They give them the illusion that
they can cycle long before they
have the competency to.
But we always have the
intention of taking these off.
Now, if you dial your fitness
life back a little bit--
we used to walk in a gym
with a bunch of machines.
Those machines aren't
there to help you.
They're there to protect you.
Sit down and push out.
You can't hurt yourself.
We tried.
We've run every idiot we could
find through the seated-- you
can't hurt yourself.
OK?
If both your hands are
here, you can't even
stick this hand in there and
let the weight stack come down
on it.
So no illusions.
We don't need to train
you by body part.
The reason we put you on
those lines of equipment
is so we don't have to talk
to you and interact with you.
And you're a rat on a wheel.
And you are burning calories.
That's right.
But you're not going to
do anything outside any
better because your
biceps got stronger.
So many of the things we
do in health and fitness
simply protect you
from getting worse
because we just don't
have the interest
or system to say exactly
what you need to do next.
Principle 1-- do it well
before you do it often.
Did I say perfect?
No.
Well enough.
2-- if we're going to
have engineered selection
of what opportunities
I should expose you to
and which ones I should
pull you back from
and which ones I should amplify
until you can read and write
them better, that's protect,
correct, and develop.
If I believe those
two things, then I
got to create a systematic
approach that works even when
I leave the room because if I'm
the only one holding those two
principles, it's hard
to put my name on a sign
and five people
do the same thing.
And we've got to have a
systematic approach in health
care with movement.
And yet, we don't.
More about that in a second.
Principle 3 guided me to create
a systematic group of filters
that allow me to use Principle
2 to enable Principle 1.
It takes a while to do this.
You read books like
Simon Sinek, where he's
talking about start with why.
And you look at some of the
major innovations we've got.
And it's just a
better why statement
that sent us to a better
how should we do that,
and what should be the outcome.
And I try to step way, way back
out of the movement sciences
and say, listen, we're
making advancements
everywhere else because we get
the bullshit out of the way.
We get the dogma out of the way.
We get the opinions and
paradigm shifts out of the way,
and oh, it's absolutely clear.
And that's the whole
point of today's message.
It's way more simple
than you think.
Now, a couple years
ago, a martial artist
showed a 14-year-old
how to break a board
with her fist or his fist.
That same board would
have broken that fist.
But under the care
of a martial artist,
with breath and posture and
everything that they did,
they're breaking a board.
Did that martial
artist know anything
about the anatomy of the hand
or how powerful the tricep was?
And did that kid have to
put on any weight at all
to break that board?
No.
There's a perfect software
programme right there.
A good martial artist,
a good dance teacher,
a good gymnastics teacher is
programming movement software
better than we are unless
they focus on success
instead of non-failure.
If you go for success too early,
you're going to hurt somebody.
You've got to
remember-- I mean, I
think we were all really happy
to see Peyton Manning go out
on top with a Super Bowl.
Most of us were, I guess.
But you've got to realize.
He's probably the last of
the three-sport athletes
we'll ever see?
Not only have most
eight-year-olds decided
on the sport they're going to
play at the professional level,
they've also decided
the position.
Everybody knew that your
last name like Manning,
you're going to end
up playing football.
But his dad was
smart enough to know
baseball instills a different
set of movement skills
and teamwork skills.
And so does basketball.
Plus, we got to
keep this kid busy.
So you got a three-sport
athlete right up
until the time it's time
to get a scholarship.
And then you use the
scholarship for what it's for.
And then you take that and honor
it with a professional career.
That's my blue sky statement.
Right?
That's the way it ought to be.
But if we don't do
something right now that's
practical and can be
implemented anywhere,
then really all I'm doing
is exposing a problem
that we all know we have.
All I did was break it down from
a series of principles that's
based on the way organisms
and environments act
in the original operating
system that you started with.
Everything I just
said you would think
is part of a standard
operating process
in health care,
teaching, coaching,
and training movement.
It's not.
I'm here to expose
common mistakes
in movement programming and tell
you how we're trying to fix it.
Much of what we're
going to cover
can apply to you
right now, meaning
you can vet some of
this stuff on your own
without a pro
standing next to you.
Steve realized very quickly
that even though he'd
met a lot of
professionals, none of them
were using a clear,
logical, standard operating
procedure for deductive
reasoning of, is this
my hardware problem
or software problem.
Not one of his 17 surgeries
was a brain surgery,
if I'm correct.
Right?
So nobody questioned
your software.
They only questioned
his hardware.
And if you've got a hammer--
If we look at your body
with an x-ray or MRI,
we can find something wrong.
Does that mean
that's what's wrong?
No.
It just means
you're not perfect.
And I think we're all
perfectly aware of that.
How do we know
there are mistakes?
Well, did you know that
the number one risk
factor for a future
musculoskeletal injury
in your life is a
previous injury?
And the second thing
is the severity
of the previous injury.
I can't do nothing about that.
I can't go back in time.
But it should make you think a
little bit outside of the box.
Most of us in here
that have been injured
enough to have to not play,
not train, or stay out of work
also met a health
care professional
that helped us with that.
Now, there's only two outcomes
when those are the first two
predictors of a future injury.
Either every injury leaves
you a little bit less
than you originally were.
Or we did not completely serve
your rehabilitation needs.
Both statements are true.
If you have a
permanent disability,
I should alert you
of that before we
cease to have a relationship.
And if you could potentially get
back to where you were before,
I must tell you if
you're there yet or not.
And just because your
insurance quit paying
or because your low
back pain is gone
doesn't mean you're functional.
See, I have a lot of people.
They're pain free
in three visits.
They still can't do that.
They still can't play golf,
but they're pain free.
So most people
after every injury
just get a little
bit smaller life.
Oh, I used to do that, but
I don't do that anymore.
I used to do that, but
So as your life gets smaller,
you're in the illusion
that you think
you're functional.
And you're not.
And then all of a sudden, you
get to go do an extreme weekend
and boom, back goes
out, foot flares up,
or something like that.
So we are the problem.
If you've previously
been injured
and you've been through
a health care model
and we didn't either alert you
to a permanent, longstanding
problem, or get you back
to what you had before,
we didn't really do
anything but stand
there while you were trying
to get better in the process.
This may be a little
bit painful to watch.
But I got a back story for it.
This is a biomechanical
analysis of a young gymnast
doing a squat.
Now, we put little markers here.
And a computer creates an
image of what she's doing,
like a moving
x-ray, if you will.
You've got blue lines
right here because she's
standing on two force plates.
And the one thing I want you
to look at, the blue line
is supposed to go through
your architecture.
That's the stress point.
That's the alignment.
When the blue line goes
outside of your joint,
that's sheer force.
That's rotational torsion.
That's basically what
happens to your ACL,
the anterior cruciate
ligament we're all
getting ready to hear about
because it's football season
and we're going to
watch SportsCenter.
And it's getting
ready to happen.
This girl, a gymnast,
blew out her ACL,
went through surgery
and rehabilitation,
and was released
both by her surgeon
and her physical therapist,
and actually went back
and started competing again and
got this biomechanical analysis
of her squatting pattern a month
or two after the entire thing
was done.
The alarming thing is they
did surgery on her left knee.
See, it doesn't matter
what her name was.
It could have been
Jennifer or Diane.
Her name on the
chart was left knee.
And the left knee
looks damn good.
They didn't fix her.
They just strengthened
her knee after surgery.
Four months after
this video was taken,
she blew the other knee
in the sport she loved.
She's part of a
female ACL epidemic.
It has nothing to do with
the way a female is built
or hormones or anything
else because those have all
been side stories
in the news we've
tried to use to explain it.
We saw this occur
when females started
playing more field
and court sports
and were allowed to at
the high school level,
but weren't allocated the same
training time as the boys.
Oh, yeah, you can play
softball, basketball.
You can run track,
do whatever you want.
There's no weight room for you.
See, we learned
that the hard way.
When we expect these young
things out of a male's body,
we give them the time and
the off-season training.
The sports-minded girls just
went from sport to sport
to sport, and never getting
the physical architecture
to support the activities
they were doing.
So if we give them
access to play,
why don't we give them
access to training correctly?
We didn't.
And we created a problem.
And now we're solving
it with surgery
instead of proactive teaching,
coaching, and training.
Return to sports
rate-- 40% to 50%
of the people who have
that ACL surgery actually
return to the original sport
at the level they were going.
The rest, life changes.
But they've also got a
30% chance of re-injury.
But it doesn't matter which
side, which tells me it's
a pattern, not a part, that's
causing these knee injuries.
And who controls the patterns?
We've got to reprogram movement.
Getting the new cartilage
doesn't do anything
if the brain doesn't
honor the alignment
and support shock absorption and
integrity of the new cartilage.
Dysfunctional movement
patterns that are habitual
rarely change unless
specifically addressed.
We've got to identify
that as not good enough.
and change it.
Her entire support system
was looking at the part.
Her doctor, her physical
therapist, her parents,
everybody said, hey, we got
a new ligament in the knee.
All is good.
You don't hurt anymore.
Oh, the scar is
looking wonderful.
Put some more Vitamin E on that.
All is good.
Nobody's watching her move.
The whole reason she blew
her knee in gymnastics,
which is not a contact
sport, is because she
was landing in valgus collapse.
But somebody was just
seeing if she could stick
or landing, not if she
landed with integrity.
And those are two
different things.
A good athlete can stick
the landing ugly as hell
because they compensate
better than us.
I got to work with NFL players
all through the spring.
They compensate
better than we do,
which is why they get
to do what they do.
ACL patients of both
sexes on average
control their body weight
with a similar level
as do 60-year-old
healthy controls.
That means regardless of
where in your life you are,
you blow your knee
out to the point
where you've got to get an
ACL reconstruction in the two,
three, four, five months
of rehabilitation that
follow that, even
with all that care,
you immediately
advanced your life.
And you're moving like
a normal 60-year-old.
I don't want that
for my daughters.
I don't want for your sons.
But that's what's going
to happen because that's
what the statistics say.
This is not simply a
sports medicine statistic.
If you're one of those
injured individuals,
your trajectory of your
entire movement life changed.
I'll bring it back around
because we got to do stuff
with these guys too.
It's almost funny to look
at "injury rates" in the NFL
because everybody in the
NFL is going to get injured
and has been injured.
It's an activity with
a 100% injury rate.
But I delivered this
statistic at the NFL
combine two years ago because
we'd go into to combine.
We're there testing.
And one of the greatest things
about doing movement screening,
what we do at the combine now,
is it sends a positive message
down through college.
If you're bigger,
stronger, and faster,
but you gave up movement
integrity to get there,
we don't want you
because you're not
going be here long
because you know
that's what NFL stands for.
Right?
Not For Long.
That's what it stands for.
OK.
That is the way that I think
the 14, 15 season in the NFL,
that's the distribution of
injuries over the entire season
over all the teams.
We see some clusters here--
ankle, knee, thigh, shoulder.
Those are big clusters.
Now, we could
individually evaluate,
do MRI's on all these parts
preseason for everybody.
Or we could simply
find a movement pattern
that confronts every one of
those joints in a pattern,
your lunge pattern,
a standardized lunge
pattern, because when you
lunge, that's your deceleration
direction change.
And that is the number one
thing in field and court sports.
That's the movement pattern
that says how durable are you.
Are you going to be able to
hold up to this kind of thing?
So that's the movement pattern.
So that one movement
pattern confronts
777 out of 1,345 of
those injuries, 58%.
I could have seen that before
because if that movement
pattern looks ugly on one side,
both sides, or causes you pain,
you're already in that group,
and you just don't know it yet.
Now, if that causes a problem, I
can easily put you on the table
and look at the knee, the thigh,
the shoulder independently.
But if I look at the knee, the
thigh, and the shoulder first,
I'll never see the pattern
because the whole is always
greater than the
sum of its parts.
And health has told you
if your parts look good,
everything else will
fall into place.
It's the other way around.
The Hall of Fame is full of
people with pretty bad parts.
They were more
resourceful with the way
they used them, with
the way they managed
their physical resources.
So here's the good news.
Since we can't go back
in time and do that,
what are the other three
factors that actually predict
your future movement
health, the obstacles you're
going to have to confront
in your movement life?
Pain with any movement test, not
joint test, but movement test.
Do a movement pattern.
Make sure it's reliable.
Did you have pain?
If so, you're already hurt.
You just don't know it yet
because your brain is already
avoiding those activities.
But what if that is the movement
pattern you should be doing?
Then we've got to
figure out why.
Ankle flexibility is showing
huge, absolutely huge.
Why?
It's the number
one injury you're
going to get in high
school athletics that's
really-- you rolled your ankle.
When the pain goes away, does
that mean the ankle is normal?
No.
No, and we've been
seeing huge things
in as many different
populations as we
can find-- fire service,
paratroopers, NFL,
14-year-old female
soccer players.
It's all the way across.
If that ankle doesn't
move, then don't just
think of it mechanically.
If that ankle doesn't move,
the sensory perception
coming up through that
ankle is just like water
going through a garden hose
that you're standing on.
I'm not getting as
much information
from a restricted joint.
So the reason we got
to do our flexibility,
guys, is not so you can
have the architecture
of a perfect joint.
The more information you
can give to the processor,
the more the processor can
do with the information.
So having stiffness
is inexcusable
if there's a way
to get around it.
So if you've got to
start your journey back
into movement health, start it
with flexibility and realize
you're not finished
when you get flexible.
You're just providing your brain
with more sensory information.
And now, you've got to
do things well enough
to adapt so you can
do them often enough.
Movement screening
and balance testing
are the other
things that predict,
is this going to be a good
running season for you.
Is this going to be a good
Spartan race season for you?
triathlete season for you?
So how do we use the
principles to fix movement?
Here they are.
But we've got to have
those systematic filters
we talked about.
Well, back in the early
days, back in, say,
the mid-'90s, every one
of us saw this coming.
We saw these bad patterns.
But we all tried to just
write new programs to keep
that from-- oh,
we just got to do
twice as much core with them.
We just need more flexibility
work and that'll do it.
And yet, a surprising
statistic came out
of the military that said-- way
back in the 1980s-- it's not
tightness or weakness that
seems to cause greater injuries.
It's left-right asymmetry.
It's when the sides of the
body just don't balance out.
And you don't have to
be perfect balanced out.
Out here at skill
level, these hands
are nothing like each other.
But if I can tell which
way you swing a golf club
or throw a ball by looking at
your core, it's gone too deep.
You've imbalanced your
body to a disadvantage.
10% imbalance we'll accept.
And it's actually
pretty normal to see.
Anything greater
than that is probably
going to start robbing
from your efficiency.
I'm not saying you
can't do your job.
I'm saying it's going to start
robbing from your efficiency.
All we were doing were trying to
write better exercise programs.
And I was part of that problem.
I was guilty too.
Right?
We're just writing programs.
Everybody, just do this
program, you'll be bulletproof.
Here, eat that diet,
you'll be bulletproof.
It's not the way it goes because
you can't fix anything that you
don't fully understand.
And I started this
off saying, we
need to read that movement code
before we start hacking it.
OK?
Oh, you've got a week core,
so 4,000 crunches from now,
you'll be perfect.
No, you won't.
You'll just be hunched
over a little bit more
because your abs are so
over-trained now you can't
stand back up like you need to.
We built filters that
capture movement patterns
below the qualitative standard,
regardless of program.
I've got no bias.
I'm certified in
Pilates mat work.
I'm certified in kettlebells.
I'm certified in
Olympic weightlifting.
I have no bias.
I don't care how you train
or what exercises you do.
If they're working for
you, I can measure it.
And if they're not,
I can measure it.
So there's 1,000 different ways
to connect you with movement
flow, with your thing.
You want to surf?
I can show you exactly
how to warm up, cool down.
Surfing might take care of every
movement problem you've got.
Do it right.
Screen it out.
Most of the things
you love to do,
we can keep you fit right there.
You've just got to
make sure you're
moving well going into it.
And then it feeds the system.
And the system keeps growing.
If you're perpetually
in an activity that
keeps you imbalanced, here's
your minimal effective dose
of supplementation
and cross-training
that keeps you balanced out.
I respect your time.
I want you to play way
more than you train.
All right?
Because when people train,
I just don't like the way
their faces look.
And when people play, their
faces just look better.
Right?
There's less cortisol in
this face than this face.
So we got a strength coach,
a physical therapist,
another physical therapist,
and athletic trainer.
Danville, Virginia,
and if you don't
know where that is and
you saw the first season
of "Moonshiners,"
that's where that is.
OK?
We're not near there.
We're that zip code.
OK?
So liquor comes in a
jar where I'm from.
Anyway, we had four
county high schools
and the city high school.
And we were
dissatisfied with how
proactive we could be
with kids getting injured.
So we had nothing to lose
because we had no research
grant.
We had no money coming
from a shoe company.
We had nothing except an
extra hour in the morning
before work started.
And I'm leading this group.
And together, we started
talking about maybe
we should do movement screening.
But we're going to do something
no one's ever done before.
We're going to build all
this disadvantage into it
to make ourselves better.
Malcolm Gladwell talked about
it in "David and Goliath."
Some of the best
situations we've ever seen
came out of constriction,
came out of limited resources.
We wanted to capture movement
signs before symptoms.
Think about that for a minute.
The reason we're making progress
with cancer and diabetes
is early detection,
not treatment.
How about orthopedics?
What do we do?
We wait until your
back's hurting.
And then we work
backward and say, well, I
think it's your core.
And then he's
going to say, well,
I think he's got stiff hips.
And I'm like, his
arches have fallen.
We're all right.
And we're all wrong
because all three of those
aren't equally part
of what's happening.
One is the bottleneck
of the situation
until we remove it and measure
the difference it made.
And then we remove the
next one and the next one.
Signs before symptoms, we do
it in almost every other organ
system of the body
except movement.
And we wait until your hurting.
And we walk backward.
And you can't deny
what we're saying
because we're all talking
chicken or the egg to you.
OK?
We wanted to capture
patterns before data points.
The patterns speak way
louder than the data points.
And the worst pattern?
That's where we look
for data points.
Right?
We wanted nearly anyone to be
able to administer the test.
The front line of defense isn't
my physical therapy office
or Greg Rose's
chiropractic office.
The front of defense
is the athletic trainer
at the high school, the
science teacher who's
coaching softball.
Right?
Your running group leader,
your yoga instructor,
that's the front
line of defense.
The drill instructor,
the fitness chief
at the firehouse, that's
who's running this stuff.
And that's what we built
movement screening for.
It must be inexpensive
with respect
to time, space, energy, and
cost, or it won't make it
to the high schools.
It won't make it to
where it's needed.
We've been movement screening
kids in Rwanda right now.
They don't have playgrounds.
They don't have shoes.
And they actually move better
than the kids in our country
that have playgrounds
and shoes and coaches
and whistles and FitBits.
We must filter for a minimum
acceptable level of movement
quality, not maximum level.
And we must check
movement competency
before physical capacity.
If we can do all those things,
I think we'll be right.
These are our standard.
Now, these are simply tests.
But ones a blood pressure
cuff, and one's an eye chart.
And even though they're test
can give us a distribution,
all we're really
looking for when
we do this is, am
I going to give you
a driver's license or not.
And it's a screen.
If you test legally blind,
then we know what to do.
We've got to go
investigate something.
And if you test hypertensive,
we've got to figure out why.
That's all a screen is for.
And that's what a
movement screen should do.
If you're not
hypertensive and you
can read the line
you're supposed to read,
get on with your life.
Vision ain't the reason you're
not going to be successful.
And hypertension
isn't the reason
you're not going
to be successful.
And if you score good enough
on the movement screen,
the reason you're
not winning races
isn't because of your movement.
It might be because of your
tactical or technical strategy.
But it's not because of
your physical presence
because people with your
exact same physical resources
are winning.
It ain't physical.
Following these
self-imposed rules,
we sort of found a GPS
of how you should move.
And we got it off the
original operating
system, these milestones.
Now, it doesn't look like this
because it's really hard for me
to get NFL players to do this.
It looks like that.
But believe it or not, even
though these don't look exactly
like exercises we
do, each one of those
is a squeeze point or a
pinch point that says,
if you don't have the mobility
or motor control to cover
the pattern, you'll flunk.
Each one of these,
if it hurts, it's
a health problem, not
a fitness problem.
And if you can't do it,
it's a literacy problem, not
a capacity problem.
You can't even read
and write the pattern.
Why are you loading it?
So we may not load
one of those patterns.
Your squat could be beautiful.
Your lunge sucks.
You don't get to
load your lunge.
I don't want to see you hopping
around with a split stance.
And I sure don't want to see
you lugging dumbbells around.
Because what happens when
we load a bad pattern?
We hit Save on a
shitty document.
OK?
We don't want to do that.
In current levels of
athletic testing right now,
it's very vogue to run her and
jump her off these force plates
and see if that knee caves in.
But when you run and jump,
that's four body weights.
That's gravity times four.
When you're just
standing there squatting,
that's gravity times
one body weight.
Why do we fast forward
and go right to here?
Because if the knee
caves here, it's
a movement reading
and writing problem.
And if it caves
here as well, that's
just magnified with load.
If it doesn't cave
here, but caves here,
we're not fit enough
to do the activity.
But if it caves at
both places, we're
not even literate enough
to take the loads.
Separating those two groups
and not seeing them same way
is literally the
technology we tapped into.
Now, it doesn't take long
to fix any of this stuff
if you aim better.
And I say this all the time.
Everybody who goes
to sniper school
already knows how to shoot.
Why are they going
to sniper school?
To learn how to aim.
They're going to hit everything
they ever aim at instead
of hoping they hit something.
And that's what I
think we do in fitness.
Oh, your back hurts?
Hey, try these exercises.
They work for me.
Well, unless you're willing to
go in their medicine cabinet
and dig all that crap
out too, I wouldn't
take that kind of advice
because all they're doing
is you're going to sample
yet another thing that
may be giving you good feedback
and you know how to measure it.
And it may be giving
you horrible feedback,
and you don't have
a reason to stop.
We built three
simple little tools.
Technology is going to come
behind us and probably improve
every one of those.
But right now, in about 10
minutes, 10 to 15 minutes,
15 to 20 minutes, we can look
at your movement competency,
your movement health, and
your movement capacity.
They're feedback loops
that feed each other.
If you screen movement,
and we find you just
can't move on one pattern,
we set you right up
with an exercise that
will help you perceive
and behave in that
pattern better.
And we retest it.
If you have pain in
any of those patterns,
we created a medical
movement screen
because we were sick
and tired of letting
injury, previously, be a
risk factor for the future.
We got to tighten it
up on the rehab end,
just like we got to tighten
it up on the fitness floor.
And if you move good
enough to learn,
let's throw some loads at
you and see what direction
you want to learn in.
Do you want to learn
to be more endurance?
to be more strength?
Do you want to learn
to be more agile?
to be more springy?
What is it you want to learn?
We can direct you right
there, and let know,
do you have a physical
barrier to skill acquisition.
Now, believe it or not we've
been adopted in the NHL
combine, the NFL combine.
We're being used in MLB.
Most of the special
operations and special forces
use what we do.
We're not really
used in grade school.
used in high school.
Some colleges do.
Some colleges don't.
We started at the top,
not because we wanted to.
We know stuff will trickle down.
Early adopters will do it first.
But it was not made
for special populations
because we can use an eye chart
throughout your entire life
span.
So I can compare
an eight-year-old
to an 80-year-old.
Or I compare an eight-year-old
you to an 80-year-old you.
We keep switching
up movement screens
every time you get older.
It's OK if you flunk a few
more tests because-- it's OK
if you flunk a few more lines.
But if I don't use the
same movement standard
across your lifespan,
I can't tell you
which way your life
should be going if you ask
me a question about movement.
I'll know I've done my
job when this message goes
all the way around the world
and comes back to Virginia.
And the cool thing was it did.
Right before I came
out here, a girl
who'd been dealing with
knee pain for two years.
Her coach had said,
go to the clinic.
Your movement screen sucks.
She was scared she's going
get pulled out of sports.
Two visits, she had two years
of knee pain for no reason.
She just wrote that letter.
And it's what people think
they have to do to move.
All right?
When animals hurt,
they don't move.
When babies hurt,
When we hurt, we still
move because we think
that's all we're left with.
And we know it's
good for us to move.
If every time you ate broccoli,
you threw up, I'd say,
quit eating broccoli
for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
If you want to see authentic
movement, just ask a pro.
And the pro is not
in the black shirt.
OK?
Here's what I want to do.
If we got time, I think as
people were coming in the door,
we asked a simple
question-- can you
touch your toes-- because we
often find a lot of people
get stuck in that
movement pattern.
So I think we asked you.
Do we have some people in here
who can't touch your toes.
All right.
Is there a medical
reason you can't?
So you don't have steel rods
in your back or anything
like that.
Good, if you would be
willing to volunteer,
I would love to see if we can
reprogram that really quick.
You want to do that?
I promise it won't
take too long.
If it does, maybe I need
to do my job better.
Who we got?
Now, we're going to try to
be as scientific as possible.
So how many people we have?
We have two?
OK, I'm going to get both
you guys to stand right here.
And face your accusers.
Feet together, touching
both at the heel and toe.
And just show us your toe touch.
That's not bad.
All right?
And what I want you to do
is step back over here.
So you didn't make it
quite to your toes.
And I want each of you
using one of these planks.
You can go on down that side.
And all I want is your toes
are up and your heels are down,
but everything is
still together.
OK?
Now, they've got to be touching.
And you can step on this one.
That way it's-- now, I'm going
to ask you to do something
that's going to feel
extremely awkward.
I'm going to ask you to
take your knees apart
without taking your feet apart.
The only way you're
going to be able
do that is to bend and do that.
And I'm going to basically
slide this between your knees.
So just bend your
knees as best you can.
And put that right between.
I'll let you do it.
Put it right between.
Yeah, good.
Little more space.
Go ahead and bend them.
Balance, I got you.
Good.
Now, here's what
we're going to do.
I want you to stand up straight
and just work out your balance.
And this may help you.
Squeeze the towel
I just gave you
and see if it helps you stand
up straight a little better.
Now, put your hands
over your head.
And just breathe for a minute.
And while your hands
are over your head,
I want you to do this.
When you bend down
and touch your toes,
I want you to go
as far as you can.
And when you hit that first bit
of tension, crush the towel.
When the towel allows you to
move a little bit further,
you still won't make
it to the floor.
At that point, cheat
and bend your knees.
But every time, I
want you to make
it all the way to the
board or the floor.
So go ahead and do one.
On your way down, you're
going to get tension.
Squeeze the towel, squeeze
the towel, squeeze the towel.
Now cheat.
Bend your knees and make it
all the way to your toes.
Bend your knees.
You don't have to hold
your knees straight.
Good, come back up.
Don't forget to breathe.
Look up when you go all the way
up, and really try to balance.
And do it again.
Squeeze first, bend your knees
second, make it to your toes
every time.
It's real good to let
that air out going down,
bring it back in coming up.
Work your balance
out the whole time.
Good, keep going.
Good, we're going to do
about three or four more
at your own pace.
But I want you to do one thing.
You're touching your toes
way better than you're
standing up straight.
So at the very top, if you
know your butt's sticking out
a little bit and your
shoulders are still forward,
really try to get
as tall as you can.
Don't lean backward, just
get the top of your head
as close to the
ceiling as possible.
Good.
Two more, each of you.
Don't forget that exhale.
Good, cheat at the
bottom if you need to.
But quit cheating if
you don't need to.
Squeeze the towel first,
bend the knees second.
This is your last rep.
And what I want you to
do before you get off
that board is hold your towel
and step forward over the board
so your heels are up
and your toes are down.
So you can grab your
towel do it doesn't fall.
Step across the board.
And now, do the opposite.
Heels are up.
Toes are down.
Feet are together.
Roll up the towel a
little bit thicker.
Put it between your
knees, and repeat.
Just like the shampoo
bottle says, just repeat.
There you go.
They're self-starters.
Ah, make it all the
way to the ground,
even if you have to
bend those knees like it
looks like a squat.
There you go.
Straighten up at the top.
Cycle those breaths.
Get your breath in sync
with your movement.
How come martial arts
and yoga and Indian clubs
are all about 4,000 years old?
And they never disconnect
movement and breath?
And we've got to remember
to breathe when we move.
Breathing was never
disconnected from movement.
Breathing is what makes
yoga work really great.
If you find out, your hardest
movement patterns in yoga
are also the ones where
you're not breathing.
Breathe first.
Then let the movement unfold.
So you're inhaling up.
Exhale on the way down.
Good.
Get those toes every time, even
if you got to bend your knees.
I like it.
Good.
You keep going, OK?
I'm going to pull
him off the board.
You keep going.
Come on.
Step off of here.
All right?
Now, just drop your arms.
Don't think about anything.
Touch your toes.
Just do it.
Good.
OK?
Let me see your towel.
I got it.
Step on off of there.
Now, don't think about anything.
Just touch your toes.
Just do it.
There you go.
Now, all I did was broke a
pattern to make a pattern.
Do I have anybody who
can touch your toes?
You can touch your toes?
Prove it.
I don't believe you.
I think everybody's dishonest
until proven otherwise.
There you are.
OK, you're not lying.
Now, I'm going to get you
to do one thing for me.
Come right over here.
Put your heels and buttocks
up against the wall.
Keep your feet together, just
like they did, but attempt
that toe touch one more time.
Right.
And that's exactly
what they felt
like because we've seen people
up here that are here, here.
Watch this.
If I take all of
this body weight
and put it forward without
putting that backward,
then I actually turn
on my hamstrings
to keep me from
breaking my nose.
And that's why you didn't
go all the way down
because you would fall forward.
What I did is made
you face uphill,
make you face down hill.
I was scrambling the vestibular
information, the inner ear
information with your
proprioceptive information
with your breathing
and everything.
And the toe touch had
been a repeated pattern
that wasn't complete.
And that's why you
couldn't touch your toes.
And so all we did
is made you balance
while you were stretching.
Because most people stretch
and then do exercise.
And it was really hard
for you to balance
when we were first going
off because you were really
stuck to the ground.
But Earth changes.
Feet have to change.
So what I did is threw you
into a much more adaptable
environment down there
and forced you to do it.
You're breathing.
And you're also touching
your toes every time,
whereas before, every time
you tried, you failed.
I had to touching
your toes every time.
And we were just taking
away your training wheels.
The first squeeze told
you to engage the front.
But when you engage the
front, what happens?
You automatically
short circuit the back.
So the tight hamstrings, the
glutes, and the low back,
they shut down when
you fire the front.
It's the way the
body stays efficient.
When I'm doing a bicep
curl, my triceps turn off.
Why waste energy?
So we had the first cue that
pinged the front, shut down
the back.
The second cue says, go ahead.
It's more important to
touch your toes than it
is to lock your knees back.
But each one of you bent
your knees less every time.
Now, if you want to
maintain that toe touch,
do that one drill before you
leave the house in the morning
and before you go
to bed at night.
And that's it.
And after about a
week, you're probably
going to adopt that pattern.
And you'll probably start
moving and dressing and putting
on your shoes in a
slightly different way.
And you may not lose it even
if you don't do the drill.
But do it consistently
twice a day.
It doesn't take nearly
as long as I took it.
I was just running my mouth.
You could have done
it in three reps.
But that's the whole point.
We sync your breath.
We make you be adaptable.
And we break a fixed pattern.
And you've already touched
your toes, and so have you.
And all I had to do was get
the old pattern out of the way
first.
So I like to do that trick.
And you guys were well
on your way to doing it.
You could have probably got
there without me because you
made an improvement.
But we've seen improvements
go way further.
So we wouldn't try to write
a new movement pattern
or change your movement
life without first breaking
some of the old patterns.
So that's a guy with
dyslexia programming brains.
That's all I got.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I work with a lot
of people with herniated disk.
And I can I use FNS to
do that same movement?
GRAY COOK: If they have a
herniated disk in their past,
but it's not
currently exacerbated.
Because any time the movement
strain produces pain,
we actually say we've
got enough information.
So we go into a lighter
load movement screen.
And I can see how that
disk is interacting.
So the minute a
movement causes pain,
we immediately
switch the filter.
And we come over
here and do what
I call a lighter
duty movement screen
to see which movement
patterns are painful
and which ones
are dysfunctional.
Let me tell you a story about
the way low back architecture.
So whether it's arthritis
or herniated disk,
we often see this.
Ah, that hurts my back!
Or ah, that hurts my back.
And then I'll say, well, turn.
Yeah, that's a
little uncomfortable.
That's a little uncomfortable.
Stand on your left foot.
Oh, good.
Stand on your right foot.
Does it hurt to stand
on your right foot?
No.
Now, every movement pattern you
saw before-- forward, backward,
rotation, rotation--
was painful.
Right?
But which one was dysfunctional.
We don't attack it.
We never work on your
dysfunctional patterns.
We become so absorbed-- I
guess because of our empathy
or whatever, we
become so absorbed
in your painful
patterns that we forget,
you've got a lot of other
patterns that are broken,
probably contributing
to the problem.
But which patterns hurt?
Because that's what
you want me to do.
You want me to make the
ones that hurt go away.
But if I do a democratic
representation
of your medical movement,
we get four categories.
Is that normal?
Touching your toes is normal.
But what if I can touch
my toes, but it hurts?
I'm actually
functional, yet painful.
All right?
What if I can't
make it to my toes?
If it's painful, I'm
dysfunctional and painful.
And that's the big
problem in health care.
Am I moving poorly
because I'm in pain?
Or am I in pain because
I'm moving poorly?
Can't answer that question.
So what we do is we would
run you through six or seven
different movement patterns,
see which ones provoke symptoms,
and which ones don't, but
yet, are still dysfunctional.
And believe it or not, we
have much greater ability
to change your
movement architecture
by removing your
dysfunction because I
can't make your back worse
working on your balance.
I can make your back
worse by forcing patterns
that don't want to go yet.
So very many times, when we
go for a medical movement
screen, which is a little bit
different than the functional
movement screen, people
think, oh, I just got a bang
through these patterns.
Well, that's how you
got the herniated
disk in the first place,
going into a pattern where
you didn't have integrity.
And that whole pain was
just a signal saying,
disharmony, disharmony,
don't go any further.
So if you've got
pain, we can easily
map out the pain behavior
and dysfunctional behavior
and have you on your
corrective exercise right away.
The movement screen is, if you
just can't do the patterns,
but it's not by pain.
So if the disk is causing pain,
different movement screen.
If it's in your history, but
it's no longer causing pain,
then we can probably
see what's left
and what needs to be done
just by doing with that.
But the minute one of
those patterns causes pain,
we do a different
test and sample it
a different way because
your category just
changed from a movement
fitness problem
to movement health problem.
Is that helpful?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
GRAY COOK: The other
thing about disk--
is it neurologically
involved, meaning a disk
that we see on MRI is
not a problem if we
don't see the nerve
problem associated with it.
If you've just got a
little bulge somewhere
but I can't tell it
from any other test,
we keep an eye on it.
But there's a good chance
that-- I don't know.
You get a little on
the other side of 30,
the disk actually
dries up anyway.
So not many people are
herniated disk after 35 anyway.
They're getting
arthritis after 35.
The disk herniation window
is between about 25 and 35,
when the disk is
still very hydrated.
AUDIENCE: So do you think
that movement issues or muscle
issues are primarily caused
by activities that we
do, like sports, or more by
posture and gentle activities
that we do for longer
periods of time every day?
GRAY COOK: I definitely
think our lifestyle
and our movement habits
are an equal contributor.
I think the reason that the
sports and the activities
compound things is
not only because we
go from pretty much a sedentary
life to a all-out weekend
warrior mentality.
But the message that we're
getting in fitness right now
is just push through it.
Work through it.
And I think in our culture,
for about the past 30 years,
we confused
discomfort with pain.
We hear no pain, no gain.
Right?
If it hurts in your
muscles, push on through.
joints, you're probably
going to blow something out.
And so that's a first
perspective difference.
But working out, being
physically active,
having a very robust
and active lifestyle,
means you're a little bit
uncomfortable sometimes.
The chair is not quite as soft.
You're sitting on
a stability ball.
But it's funny how we go
completely from comfort
to pain.
And yet, our ancestors, and even
babies, use discomfort to say,
oh, maybe I should adopt
a different behavior.
So what's the first
thing to happen
when we see the whole minimalist
running thing come around?
All right?
I'm running 10Ks in
shoes that thick.
Hey, barefoot running's cool!
Take off your shoes-- shin
splints, plantar fasciitis.
And I just cut my
toe off on a rock.
Right?
That's not the point.
These are people who actually
followed a fitness fad
and didn't grow their
self into that situation.
So I think a lot of the things
we do in fitness, there's
no filter to keep us out.
I mean, if you want to show
up to a kettlebell boot
camp on the beach
Sunday morning, you can.
And I'll show you all
the weird, wacky stuff
we do with kettlebells,
not vetting your movement,
not vetting your
metabolic capacity,
not vetting your shoulders,
not vetting your grip strength,
not even asking you if you
wake up with a stiff neck
every now and then.
So I think the access to fitness
has become so competitive
that we'll say anything to
get your ass in the door
and get you to
pay us some money.
And we'll promise you anything
without proactively screening
and assigning you the
dosage of fitness you need.
And so I tell people, let's do
the minimum checklist first.
Are you covering six to
seven hours of sleep?
Are you covering your nutrition?
Are you covering your protein?
Are you covering your hydration?
Are you waking up with pain?
Are you dealing with discomfort?
And then, what are the
activities you're doing?
And are you really
exercising in a robust way
with your movements?
Or are you just
doing the one thing?
I just wrote a article
called "Movement Food."
We're all on this
whole food kick,
meaning if you
eat correctly, you
should be able to minimize your
supplementation unless you've
got an absorption problem.
Well, if you're having fun in
your life and you're out there
and you're active and you're
always doing something,
but you don't have a
formal exercise program,
there's a lot to be said
that I may see less movement
problems in you than somebody
who is dogmatically pursuing
this regimented fitness
goal without even matching
their self to the program.
So they're both problems.
And I can tell you which
one it is with the testing,
meaning if you're asking me,
is it organism or environment,
I can easily tell you if you're
broken as far as your receiving
signals and behaving correctly.
I can tell that in about
30 minutes of testing,
maybe even less than that.
Or are you just doing
things in your environment
that aren't pointing you
in the right direction?
They're just consistently
breaking you down.
You think it's you.
It's not.
You stuck yourself
in an environment,
you don't need to be in.
AUDIENCE: What can we
do to be our own coaches
and detect broken
patterns we may have?
GRAY COOK: I think
it was in 2003,
I published a book called
"Athletic Body in Balance."
And actually, it's the other
book that you mentioned.
I wrote it for you, meaning if
you don't want to see anybody,
and if you want to work
through this on your own,
there's a way you can
movements screen yourself.
There's a way you
can confront that.
And there probably
is about a 50% to 60%
play you can resolve
that on your own.
My buddy, Kelly Starrett, has
an amazing website, MobilityWOD,
self-corrective tools.
Peter Egoscue has.
There's a lot of
self-correction out there.
The big problem
is are you trying
to fix something that's
painful or dysfunctional?
Because if it's painful,
there's something
that happens with pain.
Pain is almost like trying
to program a computer
with a virus on board.
You're better off just
not even to mess with it
because you're going
to make things worse.
And what we've studied,
we've actually created pain
where there wasn't pain.
We can inject saline in
little joints in your back
and have you do stuff.
And what we found out is if
you're in pain, when you move,
your responses to movement are
inconsistent and unpredictable.
That's not a good
learning platform.
So if you're trying to
fix a painful problem,
it's going to be much
more difficult for you
than if you're just trying
to fix a movement problem.
So if you've got a stiff lower
back and it just gets tight,
but you don't have
a pain issue, then
it's going to be much easier
to fix that on your own.
If you're in a pain
issue, it's going
to be hard for you to learn
how to do anything different
because that pain
signal interrupts
anything that could be positive
or good feedback learning.
So if it's pain-driven,
I'm not saying
you can't do it on your own.
But it's probably a
habit or a pattern that's
been there so long, we need to
put you through some filters
to catch it.
If it's just a
movement issue, you
should easily be able to
work through it on your own.
The only problem is,
you've got to be patient.
All right?
So the number one
thing people want
to do in their
fitness program is
they feel so guilty for
being in a sedentary society
that you just feel like an
extra 30 minutes of sweat
is going to somehow undo sitting
on your ass most of the day.
And it won't.
So it's better to
exercise intelligently.
And it's amazing where,
when people just get so
beat up that they just do
some tai chi for a month,
or yoga on the
beach for a month,
and they come back to it.
And they're bigger,
faster, stronger
than they've ever been
simply because they
rebalanced their self.
But if it's a true pain issue
and you haven't had resolution
with it, I would say the
best approach-- get tested
or evaluated periodically
by a professional
and fix it on your own because
a good professional can tell you
what self-help to consume
and which one not to consume.
So I don't need to
count your reps.
But I do need to point
you in the right direction
if you're not getting
there on your own.
So I think sometimes
training and coaching
is much better done
by periodic assessment
and letting you work it out on
your own with some good advice
than me standing over you
giving you words in your ear,
thinking that's going to
reprogram your movement.
So I think it's sometimes better
to involve a professional once
to get perspective.
But then it's better for you,
and it's more sustainable,
if you can be a big part of
the solution on your own.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
GRAY COOK: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]